hello and welcome to the panel channel
hosted by Z list comic youtubers ander
Mandela
I'm your host Xavier Mendez on this
inaugural episode I want to or I was s
tuba James look at this new Ben Riley
Scarlet Spider series by Peter David
this series is the triumphant return of
everyone's favorite hoodie wearing human
retcon Ben Riley spider-man's clone and
best bud who recently had a brief stint
as a supervillain where he argued that
he was morally righteous while laughing
maniacally subtlety what's that now Ben
is back with his own ongoing with the
intent to redeem his character written
by a veteran Spidey writer whom I want
to ask some very strange questions at a
convention after Ben Riley fails at
being a good villain he decides to flee
to Las Vegas so he can fail at being a
good hero in our first issue been
inexplicably has two voices in his head
representing the angels and devils that
make up his inner torment they never
show up again for some reason he also
runs around shooting people talking like
Deadpool lying stealing manipulating the
mother of a terminally ill child for
cash and taking advantage of the
mentally ill for companionship it's
pretty obvious that the intention at the
start of this book was for him to be
some kind of new character with Ben
Riley's name but I feel like the
backlash from fans was so heavy that
Peter David took a hard turn to write
him more like the character everyone
remembers or at least try to so after a
bunch of misadventures where he gets his
good costume back fights Spidey's other
clone Caine who is still alive for some
reason and then meets death you know the
lady that Deadpool and Thanos have a
love triangle with death tells Ben Riley
to stop acting like such a schmuck in
that he now operates on the Paragon
renegade system for his facial scarring
so he has to be a nice guy to look less
like a TJ Miller improvised line and we
get a story that feels a little bit more
classic
we've been bumping into the slingers a
bunch of random spider-man spin-offs
from the 90s
Kane takes more of a secondary character
position here it feels almost like a
team-up book with the two scarlet
spiders rather than a book solely about
Ben Riley then there's this current art
going where Kane is now doing all the
heavy lifting story wise while Ben sits
around doing nothing
so Kane hangs out with baseball players
and fights human hippo men no idea where
Peter David's going with this arc but I
guess I'll keep
reading alright so this book has shocked
me a bit by making it to as many as 14
issues the writing isn't bad but as you
can probably tell from the recap it's
all over the place ok well let's first
talk about the titular Scarlet Spider
Zhu Ben Riley's characterization has
gotten so muddled because there's so
many conflicting ideas of what he should
be like he doesn't currently feel like
how he did in the 90s he's just
something else one second he's acting a
lot like spider-man the next he's acting
really uncharacteristically violent and
cool and the next he's cracking some
pretty dark jokes he's bouncing around
between personalities so inconsistently
through the book that it's hard to root
for him it's one thing to have an
unpredictable main character but every
time you start to like him being one way
he pulls a 180 to be something else I
can't get attached to him as an edgy
antihero just like I can't get attached
to him as a good-hearted hero looking to
atone because he's both at the same time
and neither at the same time I have a
feeling Peter David had a really clear
vision of what he wanted Ben's
personality to be like in the series but
the backlash from fans over the first
few issues may have caused him to
backpedal in some scenes there's also
this weird lack of commitment towards
the new costume boy did they give up on
that one fast it just seems like this
series can't figure out what it wants to
be the fans and the writer are totally
at odds about what this book needs to
look like and the result ends up being
this weird hybrid of both ideas that's
so distorted it ends up leaving a bad
taste in your mouth
I'd say the saving grace of the
characters is Cain Cain is written to be
Walt himself here it's a little sad that
his own solo book ended on such rough
terms with all the side characters and
friends he made in Texas hating his guts
and losing theirs I feel like he was
really building a legacy for himself but
because of unsure sales in a poorly
thought-out crossover event he ended up
getting the shaft and his right back to
square one although I'm enjoying his
contributions to this series is the
second main character I was really
worried he'd be written out or killed
off in the first arc but he's stuck
around I'm pretty much enjoying his
subplot more than anything going on with
Ben Riley
the rest of the characters are just and
it's hard to like them or hate them they
just exist they're there so there's a
story there's Ben's boss Eva some lady
who runs a casino along with her
super-powered head of security she's
into some shady stuff and commits the
old non-law every now and then she also
has a terminally ill daughter that she's
basically forcing Ben to cure at
gunpoint which has made for some varied
scenes some good some kind of black the
villains and scenarios are also pretty
underwhelming thus far we do get to see
more of this section of the Marvel
Universe that's spider-man aftermath and
spin-offs but there's nothing super
compelling about the way it's told the
arc what the slingers kept taking a lot
of weird turns and felt like three
stories at once like okay this superhero
called the Hornet is trying to beat Ben
Riley whom he assumes as a villain
simple enough then he uses a magic
medallion to summon an elder God and
kill him because he's really sure he's a
bad guy weird but ok then he turns out
to be an obscure Wolverine villain
cyborg guy that came back from the dead
even though that contradicts what we saw
earlier you see what I mean this
sounding all over the place there were
times reading this stuff that I was
starting to wonder if it was all being
made up as he went along like one issue
gets written with no plan for what the
next one will be ok here's another
example Kane's facial scar is being
healed at the end of one issue but then
being scarred again right off the bat in
the next one with no explanation or
acknowledgement Peter David has written
some of the best comics out there and
he's probably one of my favorite Spidey
writers of all time but I just can't
help but wonder if his heart is into it
with this one as for the art well it's
all over the map too sometimes you get
really solid Mark Bagley art that's
always a joy to look at then sometimes
you get this other art that feels really
stiff and lifeless it feels like we'll
slimey's art is actually just a bunch of
tracings of only a handful of character
models because the faces are always so
similar and the body shape and
proportions have so little variation and
some of these poses look really awkward
like badly posed 3d models and not how
people move sometimes the art gets even
worse on a dialogue heavy issue I
noticed in this panel
new love interest has two left hands in
one right hand well the one hook hand
each also every episode the show will
not be posted on that other channel so
go subscribe to that the link is in the
description despite my misgivings about
it I do still find myself checking in on
this book every month to read more of it
Peter David's worst is still a cut above
the rest and I think that's attributed
to just how talented the guy really is
overall I think it has a chance to
stabilize and figure itself out as a
book but as we get further and further
into it with these issues still present
that seems more unlikely I do really
like the characters of Kane and Ben
Riley so I don't want this one to get
cancelled or awkwardly cut short before
it can shine here's hoping that with the
damnation crossover event things start
to take a turn for the better I really
liked a lot of the subsets spider-man
stuff in the Marvel Universe and while
they weren't exactly introduced in the
best way Ben Riley and Kane are two very
cool characters that I want to see stick
around for a long time seriously though
all future comic review videos will be
over there go subscribe to our Channel
what's wrong with you why haven't you
done it yet alright well see you next
month
[Music]
[Music]